alright so Michelle Obama let me ask the
panel this question was speaking this
week and she did invoke racism
she said among other things that she was
followed in stores
I imagine you remember that right you've
had that experience yeah she said we all
know the experience of going to a party
and people assume you're the help
okay this got the usual suspect very
angry Rush Limbaugh said she was playing
the race card Laura Ingraham said a
litany of victimization they act like
her very existence is kind of a
deliberate provocation but I think they
wanted her to go down to this just
Tuskegee right to this where these
working-class Alabama and kids and
actually just like give him the okey
doke right to say okay because Barack
and I are in the White House like
dingdong racism is dead that's what they
wanted her to say and the fact is we
don't do that with each other we don't
wrote to tell that lie right we actually
tell the true American story of black
people in this country which is one of
resilience and resilience has two parts
it has struggle and it has overcoming
and so often the right wing just doesn't
want wants to deny either one of those
parts right either black people never
struggle or they never overcome but yet
to see sometimes I'm so naive because on
racism because it used to be I grew up
with like George Wallace a dumb racist
that was easy to make fun of right but
but now they're like censors you know
like stupid censors are easy to work
with but real racist today they don't
say it out loud they're the scariest
ones you know and they're like liberal
censors they're the scariest what were
you in Baltimore when the riot oh yeah
but I feel you know the night Baltimore
was burning I was filming a cameo in the
new album the chipmunk movie in Atlanta
so I may not feed I could qualify to
talk about it
Hey
but he's your velvet I was arrested in
Baltimore in my life and I was in a
paddy wagon they didn't break my back so
I guess you know but at the same time
there's a cop bar I hang out and they're
very nice to me so well just depends but
I know Hills how you solve it two ways
you want to solve it what I think in
Baltimore is is one like jury duty once
a year every family has to move to the
exact economic opposite neighborhood and
live there they have to get their hair
done there they have to send their kids
to school there they got to go to the
store there and then you move back right
the other one is don't make it a race
thing make it a class thing there's just
as many poor white people in Baltimore
poor white people don't riot rich white
people do oh so good yeah rich might be
following my edge yeah yeah I mean who
would if there are any rioters in
Baldwin that were white they were up for
you but right when much like kids right
they call it celebrating okay yeah well
well did che guevara tip toilet paper
yeah I mean really I'm right I'm for
that toilet paper is expensive fortune
when you go in and why did they burn
down the CVS well that's why I don't
burn down any hundred club people always
say that well well they burned out they
burned down the CVS they stole stuff
they need it you know you need medicine
you need shops you might need a blood
pressure regulator like so but when
people say why do you burn down a CVS
why are you burning down your own
community well because of black people
being denied loans because of like
people being snookered out of their
homes and gentrify is coming in or not
coming in because that's happened you
live in a community you don't own your
winner
you're just occupying the space the
police are there you're occupying you so
when you say burn down my community what
did I burn most cbs's do not hire people
who work within 10 miles of there cuz
they're afraid of 50 them letting their
friends take something so what did I
destroy
besides the economic or economic eyesore
that won't hire me anyway over charges
me for drugs and I got away to the next
morning for my pain like you
everything Irie saying no small store
owners got burned out
that's not what I'm saying what I'm
saying is there were a litany of black
men but there who had t-shirts on
standing in front of stores protecting
stores you know that's not what the
media shows you at the media when our it
found shoot all right and found children
I said hey let's show these kids Wilin
out and make that real with the
representation of Baltimore and that was
a lot but they need to get the poor
white people to hook up with them too
because there's sandtown have you ever
been a big town yes sir you know they
team up together and they do that
inferno yes I am